-Our next guest is the
Academy Award-winning filmmake
behind films like
"If Beale Street Could Talk"
and "Moonlight."
His new series,
"The Underground Railroad,
is available on
Amazon Prime Video May 14th.
Let's take a look.
♪♪♪♪
[ Train chugging ]
Please welcome to the show
Barry Jenkins.
I'm so happy you're here, Barry.
How are you?
-I'm good, man. I'm good.
It's good to be here.
-So this is a fantastic series
that is adapted
from Colson Whitehead's
equally fantastic book
that imagines
the Underground Railroad
as an actual railroad.
I was embarrassed that as a kid,
when I first heard
the Underground Railroad,
I thought that was the case.
Colson admitted
when he was here,
he thought that was
the case, too.
And is it true that that is also
what you thought?
-That is definitely true,
but I wasn't embarrassed by it
I thought it was awesome.
You know, my granddad
was a longshoreman.
I would see him put his hard hat
and his tool belt on
and steel-toed boots.
And so when I heard
the words Underground Railroad
I imagined him underground
or men like him building
these trains and tunnels.
And I got to say, Seth,
it made me feel real damn good
It made me very proud.
-And it's such a wonderful story
because obviously it has
a historical accuracy
to the violence
and terror of slavery,
but there's also
this fantasy element to it
Was that one of the things
that drew you to it,
and is that central theme ke
to what you wanted
to get off the page?
-Yeah, it drew me to it.
And it's key.
But, you know,
I think I might have said
I imagined men
like my grandfather underground.
I didn't imagine it.
I saw it.
And so using my tools
as a visual storyteller,
I told our production designer
Mark Friedberg,
that I didn't want CGI trains,
I didn't want CGI tunnels.
I wanted everything
to be very grounded and real
You know, Colson has this joke
that kids
are going to get assigned
the Underground Railroad.
They're going to watch the sho
and tell their teachers,
"The Underground Railroad with
trains running underground."
In a way,
I do hope that happens,
because when I was a kid
and I imagined these things,
it was very mystical and
magical, but it was also real.
And we strove
for the same thing in the show
-So you obviously have
the ability
to talk to Colson throughout
this project.
With "Beale Street,"
you know, James Baldwin's
no longer with us.
I'm wondering which,
as a director,
is more challenging from you
to do the work
without being able
to talk to the author
or to do the work
with the author
being able to throw in
his two cents.
-Yeah, it was interesting,
actually.
I thought at the time
that it was
less challenging
doing "Beale Street"
because I couldn't talk
to Mr. Baldwin,
so I just stuck to the text.
I think that experience
gave me the courage
to veer from the text wherever I
felt like the show demanded it
And yet I always
checked in with Colson.
So it was kind of
a mixture of the two.
It was really nice to ask him,
"Hey, I think I want to go lef
where you went right."
He would always say, "Cool
It's yours. Go ahead."
With one exception.
But it was really nice to know
that I could trust myself,
but I could also reach out
to him when necessary.
-So you did say
"With one exception."
You basically have admitte
you had an idea that was so ba
that Colson said
you couldn't do it,
but you're not
willing to admit to it yet
-I'm not willing to admit
to it yet.
Maybe after the show is ou
for a couple weeks.
But basically, I wanted
to make two characters
brother and sister.
But it's one of those things
where it's like you don't know
at point A, and by point Z
the brother and sister.
And Colson was like --
It was the quickest reply
I ever got from him.
He was just like, "Nope."
-And he's a very nice guy.
So for him to reply that quickly
in the negative, it must have --
-Hey, can I ask you
a question, man?
-Yeah.
-I was watching the band play.
At first I thought
it was Tom Hanks
playing Fred Armisen
playing Fred Armisen.
Is it Fred Armisen,
or is it Tom Hanks
playing Fred "Middle" Armisen?
-Most days it's Fred,
but Tom begs us.
You know, I think work's
really slowed down for Tom
and so he begs us to come.
-I think the "Middle"
stands for Hanks.
-We're trying to get at leas
one little bit of Hanks
in every night
as a favor to him,
because he's a friend
of the show.
I want to talk -- you know
because obviously, you know,
this show is very unblinking
as anyone should be
when you're dealing
with the violence of slavery
But it also -- you know,
it's also about the victor
over black trauma.
Is it important for you
when you're dealing
with something like this
to also find a way to,
I don't know, put --
have overcoming in it, as well
-It is.
It's why I wanted to do it
as a series
and not a feature film.
I know the very hard images,
as I call them, can be very loud
and very lasting.
You could have three
of those and have 40 of these,
and it still might
not balance out.
And so it was important,
if I was going to
put the audience through this,
to have some sort of light
some sort of redemption,
you know, for the experience
of watching it,
the same way the character
have redemption
from the experience
of going through it.
But I think your tee-up of
Liz Cheney is exactly it.
We went through eight year
of people saying one thing
and then four years of hearing
"Make America great again,
make America great again."
I think it's incumbent
of all of us.
That's why I love that you
pull these clips,
"You said this,
and now you're saying that,"
to show what America
once was and always has been
And so some of these moments
had to be unflinching
because obviously if we can sa
make this place great again,
we're not acknowledging
what it once was.
-You got to do something
that was very, I would imagine
cathartic,
which is you got to blow up,
using dynamite,
a Confederate monument.
-I did, although maybe
I should stop saying that
because I don't know what rights
or restrictions
they can place on us.
And it's a figurative blowup
We actually didn't
get to blow up pieces of rock.
We brought rock
that we exploded on the face
of Stone Mountain, Georgia
But, yes, the same way
walking on plantations
and feeling the essence
of my ancestors,
standing on the side
of that structure,
knowing what was etched
on one side
and knowing the story
we were telling,
I did get great satisfaction
over saying, "No,
two takes isn't enough.
I think we need four.
Let's do it again.
Let's go it again."
-Yes, but let's make sure
legally people know
that you did not
destroy anything.
-Exactly.
-You used the magic
of filmmaking to do that.
-Exactly.
-You know, you obviously are now
a very accomplished filmmaker,
but this was not something
that you had your eyes
set on earlier in life.
You kind of backed
into being a film student
when you got to college.
-Yeah, yeah, that's true.
I was at Florida State
and had some friends
who played football,
and the football stadium
has a cafeteria
that's much better than
the cafeteria for everyone else.
And they don't tell you,
but they --
They can't legally say, "Onl
football players eat there."
So my buddies and I, we used t
go eat with the football players
and the film school
is also in the stadium.
So I kept walking by the sig
just trying to get really good
like, mashed potatoes
and macaroni and cheese.
And then through
those carbohydrates,
I saw this sign
that said film school
and thought, "You know what?
I think I want to try that."
And, Seth, it's crazy how making
such a random choice
has made probably the bigges
difference in my life.
-I was a film major, so I ha
the opposite path of you,
which I knew exactly
what I wanted to do.
And then like two classes in
I realized,
"Oh, this is
way too hard for me.
I do not have the attentio
to detail for this,"
because I think a lot of people,
young people think,
"Oh, my God, making movies
would be so much fun."
And then you show up
and you realize, you know,
it is this really
detail-oriented craft.
Did you take to it right away?
-I didn't take to it right away.
There was a guy in my class,
a good friend of mine,
this guy named Wes Ball,
who directed all the
"Maze Runner" movies.
He's doing the new "Planet o
the Apes" film, really cool cat.
He was, like,
just gifted from jump,
and I would have to show
my stuff beside his.
And it was like, "Oh, I can't do
what that guy does."
But then I realized --
The professor told me
we all start
with an empty frame.
And if you really take the tim
to learn the craft,
you can carry your voice
with that frame
the same way as anyone else.
And again,
it was one of those things
where I convinced myself
I couldn't do it,
like you said, and then told
myself, "That's not acceptable."
And so I took a year off
from film school
and taught myself how to
make still portraits
and things like that,
and then I came back
and I was able to put my voice
into the voice
of these other characters.
And I was like,
"Yo, no one can ever tell me
I can't do something again."
And the detail required in thi
is very liberating,
very freeing.
-Did you remember
or do you remember
the first thing you put on film?
-I do. The first thing
I put a film was --
It's crazy because this
announcement came out abou
Barry Jenkins,
one of the four directors
who might direct
the black Superman.
The first thing
I ever put on film
on a Bolex camera was my
roommate, this guy named Jarrod.
And we had this two-liter
plastic keg thing,
and I put a cape on him
and had him run
in our parking lot
and attack it.
And that was the very firs
image I ever put on film.
Very interesting for a guy
who goes on to make movies
like "Moonlight" and this show
but there it is.
-I will say that I think
every film student,
their first film stars
their roommate.
-Exactly.
-I think that's very consistent.
You recently tweeted about
a show you've been watching,
which I think maybe would not be
people's first guess
as to what you've been watching,
which is a cartoon
that aired from 2004
to I think like 2011
called "The Backyardigans.
How did this come about and wh
are you talking about it now
-I was on the couch,
and I'll admit now
I was drinking some wine.
I was on the couch and I was
scrolling through Twitter,
and someone posted one
of these songs from this sho
"The Backyardigans,"
and I was like, "Yo."
Little buzzed, and I was like,
"This song is amazing,"
and so the dog is with me.
I load it up on Apple TV.
I bought a season.
I began watching it.
And, you know,
these are such heavy times
and I'm glad you can bring
some humor to that heaviness
especially with
your intro tonight.
But they're such heavy times
I was like, "This is such
a beautiful, light thing.
I'm actually enjoying it.
Why can't I enjoy it?
I know I'm 41.
This is meant for 5-year-olds.
But still," and then the nex
day was Mother's Day,
and I just tweeted out 'caus
I got on a rant, a drunken ran
about how great the show was
I tweeted out a photo of the
woman who created the show
who was a black woman,
I didn't realize,
and, Seth, it was amazing.
There were people
all over the world
who were thanking this woman for
helping them raise their kids.
And I just thought someone els
maybe could have done this
But, you know,
here's my platform
and I just want to celebrate
this really beautiful
piece of work.
So, yes, I am now
a "Backyardigans" stan.
And I'll admit,
I'm into the third season now.
It's pretty dope. I recommend it
to all your viewers.
-I will say, if there's
one thing I can agree
that Twitter is best for,
it is people saying,
"I like this thing."
And if that was all Twitter was,
it would be a much nicer place
to hang out.
Hey, really appreciate
you spending time
with us today, Barry.
Congrats on the show.
-Thank you, man. My pleasure
And thank you for that time
met you on the red carpet, man
You always been
a real solid dude.
Appreciate you.
-I'm hoping next time
it's in person.
"The Underground Railroad"
is available
on Amazon Prime Video May 14th